M it's
God it's
God what you was trying to askos not
that was on your side cuz I'm not a
Christian I'm yeah you're not a
Christian or a Muslim I was trying to be
fair I was trying to be fair and I think
he gave you um um a verse that said let
not your will be done but Matthew 2639
talking to the father father right
father let you gave that back to him and
Him Father father but he wouldn't now
use the same ver I was like okay I see
but at the time I didn't realize so the
Islam means submission anyone who submit
his will to the will of God is a Muslim
so for example when Jesus said for
example if we want to teach the Bible
even though it's not a source of
information for us but Jesus said let it
be not my will but yours who yeah Jesus
said to to the father let it be not my
will but yours so from this this is
total submission to the will of the
father am I right and that's why if that
true story that story is true that mean
that's one of the things that shows
anyone submit his will willingly to the
will of God is a Muslim you said being a
Muslim is means one who submits their
will to God right so now I'm going ask
you this question is Allah a father in
any sense is Allah the father in any
sense yes now the issue is the
misinterpretation of the Old Testament
it's easy a father in any my friend the
misinterpretation for the New Testament
addressing God the creator of Jesus the
creator of the heavens is he a
father that's all I want to know yes do
so but you know a bit of ego and then
before he was like all right cool there
no so so do you see do you see why he
wouldn't answer that though yeah I see I
see why I see why because because it
would literally dispel his point he take
you back to exact where your exactly so
if he's using the Bible to prove that
Jesus is a Muslim then if we going to
yeah you got to keep that keep okay so
we're using that same verse according to
his verse he's not a Muslim right but he
could that's why he was in trouble right
so I was watching I was watching it back
like it like an hour and I was like
oh you know sometimes when everyone's
around you don't realize like where
you're going and before you go it gets
lost I just want to make sure I want I
definitely wanted to see you again cuz
the other ones wasn't trying to think
they just but you I was like he trying
to
cuz I'm not going cuz I think a a lot of
time you see like people like I have to
be right I'm not going to accept for you
to win this debate I'm I'm I'm open to
just be like I don't know I don't know
think I don't know but
yeah trying to bring him
over I don't have time I'm going like in
in 2 minutes like I hear you leaving
London o is those free me personally
those three are abrahamic BS why cuz
they both believe in the the of Abraham
they both the religion like like like I
said if they both believe in the god of
Abraham the god of Abraham was the
father the heavenly father and in Islam
they they say no and the god of Abraham
he's the the the father of Jesus the
Messiah now can you see why I said yes
because I talk to a guy called ABD he'll
be like no they deviated and I to you
he's like no they Dev so that's why I
take all three and read it on my own but
so I look I I leave the possibility that
I could be wrong yeah when you when you
read it on your own like you you read
the Old Testament right you read the
gospel that's what you do and okay so
you when you read the Old Testament and
you read the gospel then you read the
Quran you mean to tell me that you when
you read the Quran you see Sim you see
the same thing I see similari that's
impossible I see I see when when I read
the story of Moses I I see the
similarities what that that there was a
pharaoh involved they even get that
story wrong read yes they get that story
wrong they so there were 10 plagues you
you know what uh what's important to the
Jews right Passover right you know right
do you know that in in the Quran it
leaves that out it only lists nine
plagues when it came to God's curses on
Egypt it leaves out the Passover now why
when the world would the Quran if it's
an abrahamic Faith leave out the most
important holiday when it comes to the
Jewish and the abrahamic faith which is
Passover why do you think that is I
don't know I I'll give you the example
this what I was saying before I if I
haven't read it I I'm going to listen to
what you're saying go read I'll tell I
want you to read it okay good it's in
the book of Exodus right in the
beginning okay book of Exodus check it
out so the Passover is God's final
plague on Egypt he says since Pharaoh
didn't let my children go right and they
slaughtered my my children beforehand I
will now kill his firstborn and all the
firstborn of Egypt they're going to die
and he said that you Israel what you
need to do is you need to kill a lamb
kill a lamb use it blood painted over
the doorpost when I see that your that
there's blood of the Lamb on your
doorpost I my wrath will pass over you I
know so it so whoever's covered by the
blood man I feel like preaching
whoever whoever's covered by the blood
now this isn't new this is old I'm
listening I'm actually listening I'm
like no no no so whoever is covered by
the blood God's Wrath passes over
whoever is not covered by the blood they
get God's Wrath and his judgment so the
reason why the Quran will leave that out
is because that leads to the sacrifice
of the Messiah the Messiah is the is the
Fulfillment of the of the Passover Lamb
he's literally called in John chapter 1
the Lamb of God who takes away the sin
of the world everyone that's mentioned
that exactly so if if that's true you
have this example yeah if this is true
this is what you have in the Old
Testament you have the Passover
L be honest let's no so you're lying no
no let's work with it let's work with it
it's okay it's okay sis okay but no
let's work with it if we have we just
got to look at the evidence objectively
if we have in yes I love they said that
good so if we have in the Old Testament
this image of the Passover L we go to
the New Testament we have this image of
the Passover Lamb we go to the Quran
that eliminates the image of the
Passover Lamb you think the Quran is
consistent no in that story no but it's
essential to Salvation based on the
Passover Lamb determines if you get
God's Wrath or not if you don't have the
blood of the Lamb covering you you
receive God's judgment that's what and
the Quran leaves that out so as a Muslim
whoever's in Islam are they are without
the blood of the Lamb they're they're
they're facing God's Wrath that's why
they need the Messiah but do you do you
understand that I can when you tell me
that I can look at that and be like okay
it's not it's not there that's why I go
to the bible to read that and be like
okay that makes sense why why it's
written out of that I don't know I I I
generally don't know but this is know
knows why you you might tell me you know
why it's written now but if I read that
I can be like okay cool I believe I
don't believe in it right but at the end
of the day it's a believe ient that's
why I have these Abraham you don't you
don't regard the Quran as Abraham
because of something like this this is
essential like it's it's it's where I go
to eternal life that's not my criteria
yeah but I know it's not yours this what
I'm saying what if you're going to say
want the right one though huh absolutely
cuz I have the scriptures the Quran says
I have the scriptures like the Quran
points to me man
it said look it tells Muhammad literally
if if you're in doubt go ask the people
of the book go ask us that's that's what
it says so like it's it's not even a
stepchild you know it's not even a step
cousin it's you don't you just regard it
as it's false bro it's not in our family
it's a falsehood it's a deception from
Satan it's a simple it's that
bad a deception take care bro I love you
bro it's a deception when when when you
say things like that that's like I hate
these people so much that I must put it
down oh sorry the people oh the people
that subscrib to that book have I have I
mentioned any people no that's why I
said like I said like or the the book
I'm talk about the book okay yeah the
religion yeah the religion okay you can
say I hate the religion I do I hate
Islam I mean Islam hates me chapter 98:6
it says Those Who disbelieve among the
Christians and the Jews and the
polytheist they will go into Hellfire
they are the worst of creatures now even
though even though I know even though
believe Muslims are disbelievers I don't
think they're the worst of creatures no
no I hate
flies flies are the worst of creatures
to me maybe no cockroaches they pretty
big and fast you at snakes well yeah so
I the Quran says I'm worse than
Satan really I'm the worst of creatures
can we read that though yeah yeah yeah
cuz I I don't want to like just take
black no of course of course that's read
it says it says Those Who disbelieve
among the people of the book those are
Jews and Christians and the
polytheists will have their abod in
Hellfire they are the worst of creatures
this is uh 98:6 so look yeah yeah I
agree again I'm notlim I'm notlim he's
not Muslim
guys but I do I do take let's say I do
take heeding from the book I do I do
take Knowledge from the book The Bible
there ain't no knowledge in there there
ain't no knowledge in there don't make
me an enemy don't make me an enemy no
look if you look here it is I'm tell you
I'm with
you Lo those who disbelieve among the
people of the scripture and the
idolators will abide in the fire of hell
they are the worst of created
beings worse than a devil that's how
that's how this book regards me
so so don't I have a right to have an
animosity towards this book when it
started having an animosity towards me
that's your right that's your sub right
yeah yeah that's but but it's not even
it's not subjective it's objective I
could read that and still and still love
the book I can still read that and still
love a Christian I can still read that
and still love I'm saying you can't
you're not I know but you're not a
Muslim as a Muslim look as a if if
someone believes in Muslim can tell you
the same thing a Muslim would tell you
that be like I'm not don't have to take
then they they not not Muslim no SLE
text like that yes so if they regard
that specific text and accept everything
else they're not Muslim yeah they're not
Muslims yeah I promise you brother it's
not even me ask anybody with one of
those scarves on their head the
definition of Muslim is to to submit to
God so and everything and the prophet
and and Muhammad you can't deny look I'm
going show that's that's shahada but to
be a Muslim submit to God no no you got
to you got to look for example to say
your shahada to become a Muslim yeah you
need to you have I know that yeah I know
that but it's not even just that even in
the Quran it says that they have no
faith this 4:65 they have no faith until
they make you Muhammad judge in all
their disputes with no resistance
against your decisions and submit with
full submission yeah I heard that to
Muhammad not to Allah to Muhammad so to
be to have faith to be a believer to be
a Muslim this was when before you came
to that that shake over there this is
the the the discussion that we had I
said okay could I be a Muslim and not
even mention Muhammad he he's telling me
no you got to mention him so I was like
but then so so that means I'm I'm I have
to worship him too exactly exactly but
then when I come to you you you you say
I have to worship Jesus right a man no
Jesus Is God I I don't to that so so
when when I say I believe only in God
Jesus is not
God isran or is it in the that says
Al you know that I heard that love for
the sake of Allah and hate for the sake
of Allah I don't I don't know I don't
know I've heard it before though but I
don't know where it is that's that's
basically a tenant of Muslims where they
say because Allah hates the
non-believers you have to hate the
nonbelievers you love because of the
sake of Allah and you hate for the sake
we got to get going you got to go yeah I
mean I don't want to hold your time but
it was a good I was glad I got got the
chance to speak with you man good good
yeah
this bro I know we got more so you gotop
drop the Quran read the Bible bro I'm
not jumping none of these okay how about
this it's not an ego bro it's I love you
you I know but you're superimposing that
my way is the right way this how it's
not even mine why do I have to drop it
why encourage me to read your book how
about this how about this how about this
how about this okay how about you read
you read both right read both yeah
objectively yeah right always and and
make sure that you don't miss that the
Quran I'll just say I won't even say
what tell you what to think see if it's
a counterfeit or not check if it's
counterfeit I like that if it's not if
they're both like oh they both go side
to side they're both you know then okay
if but if it's counterfeit and
contradictory be honest about it and you
know of course that's why I'm here
that's why I'm here man that's why I'm
here I'm honest I don't know the days of
tomorrow I could be a c tomorrow I could
be a m tomorrow I could be a tomorrow I
don't know that's what I'm here if
you're if you're smart and H you won't
be a
musl oh my God I
[Music]